الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يمنح الممثل
الامريكي ستيفن سيجال اسامه صداقه
المعلومات الروسيه تقول ان الوسام بسبب
مساهمه سيجال في تطوير التعاون الثقافي
والانساني الدولي لكن لسجال علاقه بروسيا
وبوتين قبل الوسام ومنذ فتره طويله
فسيجال المولود في ابريل عام
1952 بولايه الامريكيه يعد صديقا مقربا
جدا للرئيس الروسي ومدافعا قويا عن
سياساته كما حصل على الجنسيه الروسيه في
نوفمبر 2016 واستلم جوازه الروسي من بوتين
شخصيا رافق ايضا بوتين في عدد من فعاليات
الفنون الدفاع عن النفس
وفي عام 2018 عينت روسيا سيغال في منصب
ممثل وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه الخاص لشؤون
الاتصالات الانسانيه مع امريكا اما بعد
اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا وخلال حفل عشاء
بموسكو وصف السيجال بوتين بزعيم العالم
الحر واخيرا توجت هذه الصداقه الغامضه بين
بوتين بنظر محللين بوسام صداقه